when you first got Star Trek next
Generation
I read that like is this true that they
fired you after the first season
well they don't call it firing they say
you're not asked back no you were fired
um no but you know what what here like
Maurice Hurley yes head writer and show
runner did not like working with you and
under her at her demand you were let go
is that true it was like he I think it
is true I but see I don't know that I
don't know that for sure but here's the
thing
I think they had um like I had said no
to Star Trek twice before and went to do
a play for 400 bucks a week uh with
Linda Hunt so I was not I was I was
I was a person who wanted it came from
this let's change the world let's do
something and I wasn't at all into the
business
aspect of be it theater even or uh
Cinema I didn't that that's not where I
came from I came from like okay guys
we're gonna make this the best we can
make and so many of the things that I'd
done had been collaborations like
complete collaborations with people we
would develop a piece and I loved that
so when I um or it was a brand new play
and then we'd have weeks to work on it
so I didn't get this whole Hollywood
thing and there really are politics oh
yeah well I didn't know that and I think
and also it was a different time they
really they wanted women to look pretty
and be a certain way but they really
didn't want you to like
you know speak up as if you were there
equal I think so I don't know I think I
I definitely pissed him off Maurice
Hurley because I I kept saying
why is it that I've raised this genius
kid will Wheaton's character uh Wesley
Crusher I mean the guys saved the ship
so many times right and and audiences
didn't like that in the beginning but I
mean clearly I had something to do with
it it wasn't just this dead husband and
yet every time there's anything even
possibly serious it's only the male
characters that talk to him and I know
he doesn't have a dad but all you ever
have Beverly Crusher doing is oh Wesley
you know why didn't you do that and I'm
like wait a minute she's a scientist I'm
not buying this this is like uh Leave it
to Beaver kind of
um yeah mother thing yeah and so I had a
problem with it and I thought certain
like I thought Angel one was a really
silly sexist script of
um there's this planet of women and
they're doing really well and they all
happen to be really good looking which
is you know fortunate but then all of
this
and then all of a sudden son Will Riker
Jonathan Frakes goes down and they just
they they lose their mind because like
you know it's a man it's a man I mean
things like that and I think that really
pissed I know it did piss him off and I
and Gene didn't love it either so
especially since I had been so I'm not
sure I want to do this in the beginning
right so that's what happened and and um
whereas my agent had said oh no your
character's like the third most popular
character blah blah blah I have no idea
of of any facts on any social media when
it first started no there wasn't but you
had sort of like people would still rate
things or something right anyway I have
no idea but then I thought that was over
and I went and did a play in New York
and did Hunt for Red October which was
supposed to go into being in the second
movie and then Alec Baldwin asked for
too much money and they recast both